you had this line this line that cut
everyone's imagination you say to Tom
Hanks's character I'm the captain now
and that line was something that you
improvised
we remembered us talking about that yes
you just improvise that line and then it
became this global catchphrase for you
we surprised how much that caught on of
course I was very surprised yeah I mean
it was just you would people would I
imagine come up to you on the street all
the time
Aidan if it didn't stop yeah it sounds
like it traumatized you know I love it I
think he's good it's bless yeah it's a
blessing what's the weirdest place I
mean other than just people randomly
shouting out to I'm the captain now
what's the weirdest place that it
happened to you um it was inside an
airplane yeah on my way to shoot this
movie yeah on South Africa so we land in
Cape Town and when the airplane stopped
they still would come to me I see you
say though the captain he want to speak
to you so I was I was a little sleep you
know that's as soon as I wake up you
just woke up yeah just woke up here so I
went to him and he looked at me and he
said I'm the captain now
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah you know that that guy was just
waiting it was probably a 15 hour flight
the whole time is he still back there
you know what to do you gotta get him
and bring him for yeah we know we know
we know is he still back there he go I
don't know
I often parachute out during flights
when I get bored
you